♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK, FROM
KYOTO, JAPAN, THE OLD IMPERIAL
CAPITAL FOR MORE THAN 1,000
YEARS, AND AN AWFULLY AWFULLY
PRETTY PLACE.
FINAL PREPARATIONS ARE UNDERWAY,
ABOUT 25 MILES FROM HERE IN
OSAKA FOR TOMORROW'S G20 SUMMIT
OF WORLD LEADERS.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE -- WE'LL
BE INTERVIEWING HIM.
BACK IN AMERICA, THOUGH, THE
2020 ELECTION WILL BE THE FIRST
ELECTION IN WHICH CHILDREN BORN
AFTER 9/11 WILL BE ABLE TO VOTE,
WHICH IS BEWILDERING TO THOSE OF
US WHO WENT THROUGH IT FOR YOU
DURING LAST NIGHTS DEBATE,
CONGRESSMAN TIM RYAN OF OHIO
SAID ITS AMERICA'S DUTY TO KEEP
FIGHTING IN AFGHANISTAN FOR SOME
REASON.
18 YEARS AFTER WE TOPPLED THE
TALIBAN.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE A MISTAKE
BY TULSI GABBARD, THE ONLY
VETERAN ON THE STAGE, CORRECTED
HIM.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU WILL TELL THE PARENTS OF
THOSE TWO SOLDIERS WHO WERE JUST
KILLED IN AFGHANISTAN, WE JUST
HAVE TO BE ENGAGED.
AS A SOLDIER, I WILL TELL YOU,
THAT ANSWER IS UNACCEPTABLE.
WE HAVE TO BRING OUR TROOPS HOME
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
WE ARE IN A PLACE IN AFGHANISTAN
WHERE WE HAVE LOST SO MANY
LIVES.
WE'VE SPENT SO MUCH MONEY, MONEY
THAT IS COMING OUT OF EVERY ONE
OF OUR POCKETS, MONEY THAT
SHOULD BE GOING INTO COMMUNITIES
HERE AT HOME, MEETING THE NEEDS
OF THE PEOPLE HERE AT HOME.
WE ARE NO BETTER OFF IN
AFGHANISTAN TODAY THEN WE WERE
IN THIS WAR BEGAN.
>> Tucker: ALL OBVIOUS POINTS.
NONE OF WHICH YOU ARE ALLOWED TO
SAY OUT LOUD IN WASHINGTON.
NOW THEY MAKE CONGRESSWOMAN
TULSI GABBARD SEEM LIKE
BASICALLY AND UNTOUCHABLE.
SHE IS NOT ALLOWED TO GET THE
KIND OF COVERAGE THAT THE REST
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        D
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        M
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        C
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        A
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        I
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        C
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        N
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        I
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        A
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        E
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY        S
GOOD FOR THE VIEWERS LOVED IT.
IT AT THE DEBATE, GABBARD'S WAS
THE MOST SEARCH NAME ONLINE.
TULSI GABBARD OF HAWAII JOINTED
TONIGHT.
ALOHA, CONGRESSWOMAN NUNES WOW
GABBARD.
>> A LO HAW
, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I'M SURE YOU DON'T
WANT TO PLAY THE VICTIM BUT
DESPITE THE FACT THAT YOU WON A
NUMBER OF ONLINE POLLS, YOU HAD
THE MOST GOOGLE SEARCHES, YOUR
NAME, YOU GOT SOME OF THE FEWEST
MINUTES TO SPEAK OF ANY OF THE
TEN CANDIDATES ON STAGE.
YOU WERE THE ONLY ONE WHO WAS
ESSENTIALLY ATTACKED PERSONALLY
BY THE MODERATORS.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT WAS?
>> LOOK, IT SHOWS THAT THERE IS
A CLEAR BIAS IN PLACE.
I MADE THE MOST OF EVERY MINUTE
THAT I HAD, WHICH I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE MORE TIME TO
ADDRESS THESE IMPORTANT
ISSUES.
BUT I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
SOMETHING FROM THAT CLIP THAT
YOU PLAYED THAT I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT, WHERE WE HEAR
A LOT OF POLITICIANS SAY THE
SAME ARGUMENT THAT, WELL, WE'VE
GOT TO STAY ENGAGED IN THE
WORLD, OTHERWISE WE'LL BE
ISOLATIONIST AS THOUGH THE ONLY
WAY THE UNITED STATES CAN ENGAGE
WITH OTHER COUNTRIES IS BY
BLOWING THEM UP OR STRANGLING
THEM WITH ECONOMIC SANCTIONS, BY
SMASHING THEM AND TRYING TO
OVERTHROW THEIR GOVERNMENTS.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT IS WRONG
WITH THIS WHOLE PREMISE AND THE
WHOLE VIEW WITH WHICH TOO MANY
POLITICIANS, TOO MANY LEADERS IN
THIS COUNTRY, ARE VIEWING THE
UNITED STATES' ROLE IN THE
WORLD.
HOW ABOUT THE UNITED STATES BE A
LEADER IN THE WORLD, WORK OUT
DIFFERENCES AND BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH NEGOTIATIONS
AND DIPLOMACY AND FINDING COMMON
INTERESTS AND SEEING HOW WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER, SO WE CAN STOP
SENDING OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM INTO HARM'S WAY, SERVING
IN MISSIONS THAT DO NOT SERVE
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THAT MAKE OUR COUNTRY
LESS SAFE AND ACTUALLY END UP
CAUSING MORE HARM AND MORE
DAMAGE TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRIES WHERE WE WAGE THESE
WASTEFUL REGIME CHANGE WARS.
THAT IS A KIND OF CHANGE
LEADERSHIP I AM HOPING TO BRING
AS PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST MENTIONED
SANCTIONS.
YOU ARE NOT QUESTIONING THE
IRONCLAD BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS IN
WASHINGTON THAT SANCTIONS
AGAINST IRAN ARE MORALLY
RIGHTEOUS AND CAN NEVER BE
WITHDRAWN, ARE YOU?
>> I AM, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THIS IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS LEADING US CLOSER
AND CLOSER TO A WAR WITH IRAN, A
WAR THAT WILL BE FAR MORE
DEVASTATING THAN ANYTHING THAT
WE SAW IN THE WAR IN IRAQ.
A SURGE IN IRAQ IN 2005 FOR THE
MEDICAL UNIT.
THIS WAS THE HEIGHT OF THE IRAQ
WAR.
THERE WERE LOTS OF AMERICAN
CASUALTIES ALMOST EVERY DAY AND
I WAS CONFRONTED WITH THAT HIGH,
TERRIBLE HUMAN COST OF WAR, A
WAR WITH IRAN WOULD MAKE THAT
THAT WAR WITH IRAQ LOOK LIKE A
PICNIC.
ESCALATING THIS CARD, CRIPPLING
SANCTIONS, WITHDRAWING FROM THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL, DESIGNATING
AROUND SMEAR MILITARY AS A
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION,
SOMETHING UNPRECEDENTED, AND
CONTINUE TO DEPLOY MORE AND MORE
U.S. TROOPS.
THE NEOCONS OF A TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND
SAUDI ARABIA AND NETANYAHU HAVE
CREATED THE SITUATION WHERE IT
IS GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP TO AVOID A
WAR WITH IRAN.
THEY HAVE BUILT ALL THE BUILDING
BLOCKS, PLACED THE DYNAMITE, AND
LET THE FUSE.
IT IS GOING TO BE UP FOR
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS LEADERSHIP,
WHETHER OR NOT HE IS GOING TO
CUT THAT VIEWS AND SAY, HEY, WE
NEED TO GET BACK ON TRACK AND FR
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEO
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEL
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEE
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEI
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEN
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEO
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PER
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEC
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEU
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PET
THE INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEY
FIRST.
AVOID A WAR WITH IRAN, .
>> Tucker: THIS IS WHY THE
NEOCONS HATE YOU MORE THAN
ANYBODY.
[LAUGHS]
MORE THAN ANYBODY.
THEY ARE WRITING PIECES ABOUT
YOU RIGHT NOW.
CONGRESS OH MY TULSI GABBARD --
>> AS HE POINTED OUT, REALLY
QUICK, THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN,
DEMOCRAT, PROGRESSIVE, THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT TRANSCENDS PARTY
LINES.
I THINK THAT IS WHERE THE
LEADERSHIP I BRING BRINGS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UNIFY THE COUNTRY
TO MAKE THIS KIND OF CHANGE THAT
IS IMPORTANT TO EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THERE'S NOTHING PARTISAN IN THE
SLIGHTEST ABOUT THIS AT ALL.